okay so the first one is the guy comes
in just coming in I'm going to deviate
I'm going to flank and then attack flank
and attack so that's the first
one flank back
in flank back in you kind do it with a
big tank
con do with a small
one
then he counters that so I
take but my attention is still
there he counters it that's what opens
the
[Music]
elbow not me going out
here I attack he counters that opens the
elbow
we this do the adem
me
just that first step
go counters boom I'm going to
take the other leg out A variation
and watch his other leg I'm going to
come in and sweep it
out so nobody ATT is
here now I'm going attach that other
leg all
right I don't care which leg which base
deconstruction you want if you want EQ
you can but we'll go here
okay so trapped in the hip get all your
weight in here so you can actually
dislocate
it if you want to attack the leg you can
it's exactly the same all the weight in
here get it so you can
apply all of your back
muscles oh you can do hip boom here
or leg same exact
[Music]
one
br
[Music]
come
for